R
MORE.
GAYLE.
>> THANK YOU, ELIZABETH PALMER
IN LONDON.
>>> MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
CANCELLED AIRLINE RESERVATIONS
LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS, AND MOST OF THEM
DID NOT GET THEIR MONEY BACK.
NOW TWO U.S. SENATORS ARE MOVING
TO FORCE AIRLINES TO GIVE THEM
THE REFUNDS.
KRIS VAN CLEAVE HAS OUR STORY.
>> Reporter: SHELLI McCLASKEY
WORRIES SHE MAY BE OUT NEARLY
$900 FOR FLIGHTS SHE AND HER
FAMILY DIDN'T TAKE LAST
CHRISTMAS.
>> WE THOUGHT THAT, YOU KNOW,
THINGS MIGHT OPEN BY THE END OF
THE YEAR.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL THANKSGIVING
THAT WE REALLY THOUGHT,
CALIFORNIA AT THAT TIME, LOS
ANGELES AREA WAS SHUT DOWN EVEN
MORE.
SO, WE JUST DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
A GOOD IDEA.
>> Reporter: THEY CANCELLED
THEIR SOUTHWEST AIRLINES TICKETS
AND WERE GIVEN A FLIGHT CREDIT.
SINCE HE BOOKED THE TRIP LAST
JUNE, THAT CREDIT EXPIRES NEXT
MONTH, BEFORE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
USE IT.
FLIER COMPLAINTS OVER REFUNDS
SKYROCKETED LAST TO LESS THAN 16
IN 2019 TO 89,500 IN 2020.
AND "CONSUMER REPORTS" HAS SEEN
A 10% INCREASE IN FLIGHT
VOUCHERS SINCE JANUARY.
COMPLICATING THE ISSUE EVERY
AIRLINE POLICY IS DIFFERENT.
>> IT SHOULDN'T BE UP TO THE
AIRLINES TO DETERMINE WHEN A
PASSENGER FEELS COMFORTABLE
FLYING AGAIN.
IT SHOULD BE UP TO THAT
PASSENGER.
>> Reporter: MONDAY SENATORS ED
MARKEY AND RICHARD BLUMENTHAL
BOTH DEMOCRATS SENT LETTERS TO
ALL U.S. AIRLINES DEMANDING
FLIGHT CREDITS ESPECIALLY THOSE
ISSUED DURING THE PANDEMIC NEVER
EXPIRE.
>> THE AIRLINES SHOULD REFUND
THE PRICE OF THEIR TICKET.
THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT.
THE LEAST THAT THEY SHOULD DO IS
EXTEND THE EXPIRATION DATE OF
THAT TICKET.
THE AIRLINES DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT.
>> Reporter: WHILE THE NUMBER OF
FLIERS IS ON THE RISE, PASSENGER
LEVELS REMAIN BELOW THAT OF
2019.
U.S. AIRLINES ARE STILL USING
ABOUT $100 MILLION A DAY.
IN A STATEMENT, AN INDUSTRY
TRADE GROUP SAID MANY AIRLINES
CREATED VOUCHER POLICIES
EXCEEDING THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION'S GUIDELINES.
McCLASSKY SHE'S BE FLYING A
DIFFERENT AIRLINE GOING FORWARD.
>> WE'LL MAKE THEM SUFFER USING
OUR MONIES AT ONE OF THEIR
COMPETITORS.
>> Reporter: NOW AIRLINES IN THE
U.S. DID GIVE ABOUT $13 BILLION
IN REFUNDS LAST YEAR OF 72% FROM
2019.
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND ESTIMATED AT
LEAST 10 BILLION IN THESE FLIGHT
VOUCHERS.
SOME OF THOSE ARE STARTING TO
EXPIRE.
THAT'S WHY THE SENATORS SAY THE
AIRLINE INDUSTRY HAS TO DO
BETTER OR THEY'LL LOOK AT
WRITING LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE
IT.
SOUTHWEST DID EXTEND SOME
VOUCHERS BUT SAYS IT ALSO HAS A
CASE-BY-CA